[Music]
so you're the one that likes shitty
music when you were in high school
um oh yeah no you were you just had such
great taste yeah bro all i listen to was
like sinatra
that's true though
that's a good sinatra was the man i had
lube
lubaga's entire cd the entire first
album i had it let me tell you something
mambo one through four [ __ ] sucked
mambo six though
mambo six not bad back to form but um
and my favorite was too fast too mambo
um i [ __ ] hate you and then there was
nothing that was the one with tyrese did
some trash right then the one little bow
was mambo number eight tokyo trip
that's not even the right sequence i
know anyway
um
well uh i know you did you like did you
like taking back sunday
huh uh yeah cool well can i
can i introduce you to take him back
monday
that's not the name of the band but
that's what i'm calling it tim
oh god
okay so
right away we can say this thunder hit
by the way as i hit pause i just want to
say by my house thunder hit as i hit
pause
yeah that's god warning us
um
this is
this video right now here this is the
all the proof i needed definitively
to declare the tim poole in that entire
compound of people
does not have one friend
you're right
right
if if i
all of a sudden royce decided
you know royce my main passion really
has just been music
and i just started a band
like
you would probably pull me aside right
and go dude i think it's i think it's as
late to start a band as it is to try out
for the [ __ ] miami dolphins
you know what i mean it's a little late
yeah maybe put it away maybe the jets
they need a quarterback um yeah i might
have a shower jets at least a backup
yeah i'll still get a ring yeah well you
know no because we'll never win anything
but you know yeah
but but i could just get a ring that
says new york jets well
but but to bring up to actually say what
that into what you're saying like i i
this is what what you're seeing now is
who temple wants to be
he doesn't like what he is i mean you
know i'm sure if you walk into this
guy's place he's probably playing
acoustic guitar like a douche bag at
every college party
you know you know that at every college
party there was a douchebag
that was always playing like the first
three chords of like a song that
everyone knew but then he would [ __ ]
tease you and wouldn't play the song and
i'd be like bro you're so [ __ ]
annoying
um it's like you said guys that's
walking towards it and you're like just
stop no ah
knock it off we're not doing that we
have we have
we have a we we have a bluetooth speaker
we don't need you to play okay we're
good all right we're gonna listen to a
playlist i made that doesn't have your
shitty music in it
but
the music video is pretty cool
oh by the way this is just a clip the
the video doesn't come out till august
26th so we have we have oh no
oh man
hey mark what a bummer i want to remind
you of something
august 26 is friday
um
friday frozen sends us videos
i'm just putting that out there i have
no new knowledge but i'm worried about
it
[Music]
honestly then it's probably fate
that if this comes out on the 26th
and whiskey's fighting that filipino guy
on the 27th
this has to be his entrance music right
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god i have the first single
it's not a video but it's a song i have
it
[Applause]
nice generic riff
it sounds like an aew wrestler wrestlers
coming out
[Music]
sounds like the police covering the
eagles
[Laughter]
you're right yep
no it sounds like puddle of mud covering
the police covering the eagles
but it's a bad company song and they
don't really invent it but it's also a
big company
come on you know tim poole
tim poodle of mud
damn it oh
[Music]
[Applause]
he really [ __ ] thinks who the [ __ ] he
is huh
he really thinks he's going to [ __ ]
like transcend his artistry into another
feel like he's going to be him he's
going to be one of those guys wow man
you know what
that guy he's skateboards he's a [ __ ]
rocker man he's a rock star and he's a
[ __ ] debate guy may's a triple threat
okay i gotta tell you something i hate
that i have to agree with people that
that i hate but like remember yesterday
we played the crowder video
and i believe ethan klein was like wow
man this is bad like even for you and
we're like [ __ ] he's right and now tim
haydaker commented on this who i hated
hi decker and he goes
wow man this sucks that's all he said
like
and i'm like [ __ ] god damn it i hate
these people but they're right
[Music]
ew
because the [ __ ] democrats are nazis
do we have to have such literal lyrics
about it yeah but he's a hack i mean
what are you gonna have you know i'm
surprised all those music videos aren't
him skateboarding to be honest with you
so we're lucky this is what we have
hey by the way tim pool you're never
gonna be a rock star you're never gonna
be a lead mate and i'll tell you why
you're never gonna be a leading man
because
at least like when you compare yourself
to other people who are good at this
like for instance billy corrigan
when billy smiling politely yeah and
when billy corgan's hair started falling
out he just picked his head reinvented
himself he didn't walk around the same
smelly beanie to go meet the [ __ ]
president
[ __ ] god he met the president with a
[ __ ] beanie on god damn it
didn't you get a squid and take that
like honestly i don't have a suit right
now that is he that either fits me or is
in good shape like i have one or the
other like if we went to meet somebody
like the governor or somebody i'd have
to go probably get a suit for this but
like
we would get suits for that right yeah
of course you go get it oh you go oh
[ __ ] i gotta go get suits i guess we
have haircuts somebody has to go to the
men's warehouse this weekend
honestly though even that just
hit up with joseph a bank on the way to
the white house well the trick is the
trick is if you need a suit right away
go to one that has a tailor already
inside of it because some people make
the mistake of the they go to these soup
places like oh they're great the prices
but then they don't have a tailor so
then you have to go find a tailor yeah
or you got to wait for their guys oh
yeah yeah we'll get we'll come back here
in a week and pick this up i'm like no
that's [ __ ]
that's like still the the most
embarrassing thing tim pool's ever done
which is a long list of things it's like
you didn't with the money you make
you didn't [ __ ] go to a barber and
then immediately go pika and literally
say when you walk is he's obviously a
man who's clueless about clothes
um
i mean we're slightly less clueless
about clothes but i'm clueless enough
that if i was gonna go meet somebody
important i would go in and i would ask
a tailor yeah i would ask somebody i'm
going to meet
the president of the [ __ ] united
states
what would you wear you know i mean like
they go all right right this way you
know what they would do you know what
they would say a wire
because you came to the fbi
fashioned by ingrid oh my god that's so
funny and they're like look we're gonna
we're gonna bring this in uh we gotta
hem it yeah we're gonna bring in the
waist a little bit give me a couple
minutes i can show up with a wire
and then every time you get on the mic
merch it feeds back because of the wire
you're wearing
i don't know why it starts with me i
don't know why it's just with me that's
weird that it's just with me we're
mar-a-lago at a reception and every time
we go to see karaoke the [ __ ] thing
starts squealing i'm like that's so
weird
you're actually here it's picking up the
guys in the van oh [ __ ] coming into me
sorry
[Music]
part in me while i burst
into okay so he's incubus he wants to be
incubus now too i don't know what he
wants to be man
i'll tell you what he doesn't want to be
i'll can i tell you who he doesn't want
to be tim poole and that's what eats at
him every now every [ __ ] day of his
life you're right that is why like a
[ __ ] cancer is eating him from the
inside out because he can't just be the
beanie alone is proof
that he can't just be comfortable being
tim pool the man is unwilling to even
show you his forehead
[ __ ] nuts
[Music]
this is like when a band you like
starts sucks plays into
starts playing their originals
and you're like oh god i'm gonna go get
a beer this is when you go get like you
go to the bathroom at a concert you know
you're like i gotta go pee i gotta go
pee they're gonna do originals real
quick you know i don't want to really
care hey
let me know let me know when incubus
plays drive okay just text me when it
starts i'm gonna be outside i don't
really care about their new stuff yeah
they're doing a bunch of new [ __ ] yeah
it [ __ ] sucks um i know this is what
he wants to be
and look by all means go ahead however
just like everybody else in music i'm
going to make fun of you because you
suck
and this is [ __ ] terrible and it's
sad everything about this is a try-hard
thing bad and you should feel bad
you know that's like if tomorrow merch
and i decided you know what this show
cooking show and it's both of us just
wearing for no we we don't tell anybody
and then for no reason we start wearing
aprons and doing recipes people will be
like this is not really we're like look
this is what we always really wanted
okay support us or you you're a [ __ ]
democrat
because that's what's going to happen
tim no it would also be like support us
or you're a democrat but we're also
making food poorly
like it's not even it's not even like we
switch to a cooking channel but we still
have chemistry and we're cooking up
really good food it's like we decided to
start a cooking channel to make [ __ ]
and slop and everybody's like you know
did the old show was actually better oh
my god i read the comments i'm so sorry
i'm not even gonna do it i can't i don't
want to see them i don't want to see
them i don't want to see them i'm sure
they're all sick
can i can i put money on something can i
put something
he's got a weird cult
tim paul should do a song with tom
mcdonald's gonna be in that [ __ ] i love
it yeah
let's play let's play uh the merch
comment game bingo okay go ahead before
i okay go give me give me your before
before you see him give tell me what
we're looking at what do you guys think
what are the some comments we're gonna
get
but i gave mine okay
there's gonna be yeah the uh you should
do a song with tom mcdonald there's
gonna be a lot of like
quartering types popping up to kiss his
ass too just so that they have a top
comment
there's gonna be like got like they're
gonna be some of those little verified a
verified sex and hammers and stuff going
on in this pretty good stuff
all right ready
here we go
uh
so let's see here uh that's why it's
called the revolution it always goes
full circle
other than that excellent song awesome
animations that's pretty great
uh the next one the one that made me gag
you either die a hero you have long
enough to see yourself become the
villain
uh the chill that goes down my spine
when the lyric changes from uh gun those
rebels down to gun those fascists down
the chill went up his spine
in this song um
really
probably douche shells i like how the
video is apolitical and it doesn't
condemn just one party it condemns all
tyrannical governments oh wow oh cool
man what how about just making like i
don't know a [ __ ] good song
this is this is
uh i mean like you know look at like uh
uh
we call what's that [ __ ] song possum
kingdom by the toadies this song is
literally about basically raping and
murdering a woman dumping her in a lake
and that song rocks larry banda this is
actually a better song than what's
running at number one on the radios
right now oh my god it's not boomer it's
not you're just [ __ ] boomer
you're part of a parasocial cult of
personality
out of the
and then you're going to go to business
for yourself and [ __ ] bury hangman
adam paige so much so that i start
defending butterfly pants
um
the wheel of statues was such a
beautiful metaphor
you know what i but this is why i could
never be
like a huge creator i could never build
a huge audi like this is like when
people just go like oh you know mercy so
like jaded mean to the audience because
if anybody if like i made a music video
that bad i'd be aware how bad it was and
if people came up to me and went wow man
that was like actually like a deep
metaphor that'd be like shut the [ __ ] up
that sucked
hey royce check your dms
oh royce gets dms cool
yeah well he's the one like that's
actually the control of the show that
does work yeah um
holy crap i don't know uh music oh no
come on [ __ ] you virgie you i would you
should have said it to merch
god damn it's here let's [ __ ] god
damn it well
one point for virgie
holy crap i didn't know you did music as
well tim you should definitely add more
to this add more of this to the live
show honestly now i'd love to see you do
a collab with tom
mcdonald
i call that the i i call that merch's uh
tom mcdonald theory
it was you can't go anywhere into
right-wing griff music without
somebody asking for it it's in every
single comment section it's like a
[ __ ] law of the internet oh my god oh
my god i just saw something you're gonna
love i was about to move away from this
but now i can't
eve six eve six tweeted him eve six
remember ev6 oh god yeah
man i've written some awful lyrics in my
time but never have i come close to
anything as unoriginal and redundant and
as banal as
starting at the heartache in your soul
as your heart fell to pieces eve six is
dunking on
i'm going to retweet this eve six
is dunking on tim pool right now on
twitter
wow e6 is talking about me bro i used to
play a bunch of your songs with my
garage band shout out bro so he's trying
to turn it around own it and be cool
yeah i'm cool guys bro we're gonna cover
inside out and play it live
okay that's just
is he
brian
you know what tim poole guess what i'm
knocking you down another peg i respect
brian stelter more than you because even
he'll walk around with that horseshoe
bald head